When I was with my narcissist,
I remember I could pick up on all his weirdness,
like, all his red flags and all,
like, the things that, like,
really made him unsavory to be around.
But I was like, oh,
you know, you can write a lot of those things off.
And then when we went out,
like, in public,
to parties and stuff, I was like,
do other people notice what I noticed?
Like, I was always just really confused.
I couldn't tell. Do they pick up on his weirdness and I'm the weird one,
or am I the normal one and I'm, like,
legitimizing him because he's so weird,
but clearly he's with a normal person?
And then when we finally left,
and I was, like,
talking to some friends, and I was like,
you know, I kind of asked them that,
and they were like, oh, no,
he. We.
Everybody could pick up on how fucking weird he is.
We just figured if you, you know, you're normal.